I truly enjoy coming to work every
single day on this set I think we hit a
lot of topics and though we're funny
about it we slip in a message that
people can really relate to the kitchen
of what family life is like we're moving
back to Columbus Kiyomori hardrick you
have your pick of anything you want to
do family reunion comes across your desk
what makes you say I have to do this
project because this is actually my life
a lot of people they don't really know
this but my mom she's very into the
church so a lot of what m'dear says and
who's played by the wonderful Loretta
Devine the family reminds me of growing
up with my family tell me about my dear
well you know my dear is the first lady
of the of a Baptist Church in Columbus
Georgia Richard Roundtree plays my
husband who is the rep we are very
faith-based
home and I raised my son Mose who is
just the opposite I don't think he's
been to church in a long time yeah and I
find this out when he comes home with
his new wife which I have to get used to
because her ways of doing things are
just so different from the way I brought
up my kids and so it's an interesting
story I think that people are gonna love
I think that we're gonna have people
taking sad so I oh that's the way I
would do it oh no I would never do it
that way these aren't jeans these are
mine oh I think they look cute sure if
you're dropping it like it's hot at a
Nicki Minaj concert
you have me literally cracking up
whatever you're in a scene but
particularly opposite T amore hard yeah
yeah yeah I mean as soon as I found out
that Tia was gonna be coke I was like
yeah I knowed it out on it and then you
know as soon as we hit the first scene
we started joking around and between
takes and we just got really you know
close and I think it just worked because
she's kind of a goof all the same way I
am it feels natural kind of being in
scenes with her so and we know how each
other apart it's great fun and friendly
Jayde
but then this says sophisticated and
approachable which says dressed in the
car Jane my character is Jade she is a
quick-witted um very lovable person
she's kind of gotten to be her own
person and played by her own rules and
all of a sudden moving in with m'dear
things become a little new to her I'm
Shaka
I'm the rambunctious smart and charming
one and I'm the biggest prankster in
real life and I am mozzie and I'm a very
curious person and I I love my family
very much but me and my brother are
always getting tangled in some kind of
mess my character is ami she likes to
read books the Bible
she's like a small my dear except she
doesn't like church
remember church starts at 8:00 a.m. we
don't go to church dances we belong to
bedside Baptists start praying before I
forget I know Jesus Coco the character
that I play she reminds me so much of
myself yes as I'm as a mom no one very
new age they kind of say like the
Millennials
and the way I raise my children it's not
so traditional
I'll give me an example I love to Co
sleep with my children so what that
means is my son he got out of our bed
meaning my husband and myself our bed at
the age of four and some traditional
parents are like oh my gosh what about
the cry out method I don't want to do
that another example is Coco she lets
her children choose their punishments
should I say so when they get into
trouble we talk it out you know like
let's talk this out and that's the way I
am the new school yeah the new school of
discipline that's the way I am in real
life I'm nothing like my character I've
never had kids myself so this is all
acting but the captor sort of grows on
you because we've we've done quite a few
shows and so now I find myself boss and
the kids around offset I just I'm beat
me you know and it's weird there's no no
character development needed Mo's and I
are you know both former football
players both kind of goofballs both dads
enjoy a good time and when it gets
serious and to the discipline I think
that's the thing that we both kind of
are parallel with chemistry that we see
on-screen between the cast it's it's
electric it's like you guys have been
working together for years what did you
do when you first met with each other to
say like let's bond let's get the
connection going
absolutely fell in love with TIA gia is
just a jewel she screams your name
whenever she's just you know she makes
me feel so special and I could say the
same thing for Anthony he has so much
charm and he's so gorgeous there's
nothing that Isaiah CJ and Jordan cannot
do and oh my god - leah has an opera
voice that no one has even heard yet so
they're just so gifted snap the ends up
while we engage in conversation that's
what the old photo
snapchat I take really great advice
where she she told me that you don't
care really care about what you're doing
take pride in your work and really enjoy
yourself and Richard some nice stories
from back in the day so it's fantastic
to kind of sit with him and outside of
the trailer and hang out and talk and
good dinner I'm just soaking it all and
I'm just taking it in I love it but I
don't know if the writer wants me to say
this but she has this amazing technique
it like remembering wine see the word is
like get ready to go to school she'll
right now far yeah she'll put it down
like on something and then like read it
like that and then she like memorized
it's incredible Tia Mori hardrick yeah I
mean she plays your mom on the show yeah
what is it like when you're in a scene
with her she's such like a mom in
general just like her she's just so
sweet and caring and like it's always
taking care of us and she does what has
she had done for you she has been very
helpful for me she's always send me a
nice thing for me family magic is being
together sticking together and pray
together
[Music]
we were up watching you I'm loving you
oh I think an you were the kid on this I
know well now you're the sophisticated
model in the show is that [ __ ] strange
to you it's yes it is very strange but
what was so mind-blowing to me was when
Jackie Harry came on the set she was a
guest on the show and I'm acting
one-on-one with her and I'm not calling
her mom I was like oh my gosh like this
is like crazy
your husband's such a talented actor
yeah II know your son has kind of got
the bug a little good job you know he
did an episode family I think that was
my question let me tell you I was
sweating bullets when he did the
run-through which is where all of the
actors who act out the whole script and
you're in front of really important
people like Netflix execs the creator
the writers and if it doesn't hit I'm
telling you I've seen it many times
actors getting placed okay and he
freakin nailed it cut - he has an agent
and a manager already know yeah
[Applause]
[Music]